see me a line of fire
hinton a new album in a new language be
shown dubis attract inspired by her son
is a single off Sarah Connors first
German language album the title mutters
praha aptly translates as mother tongue
van god why german i guess it was hired
the idea for switching from english came
on a german TV show in 2014 we're
leading musicians perform each other
songs Connor covered a track by singer
Clegg or myla does factory too often
that's where it really began showed me
it works in German to you just have to
find the right words on the right
melodies and then it can really hit you
with fish McClure she managed to recruit
composer Wolf's Lair Zoma and Peter
platter the singer-songwriter behind the
walls and starts to work on an album in
German
as a sarah connor condition at village I
thought I kind of knew Sarah Connor and
an absolute and then I heard her singing
in German and Thor no way I was totally
taken with her voice it was so different
and I became a fan on the spot I'm Gus
until it's right before the reason fair
Connor his father is American had
previously sung in English only her
debut album in 2001 was a smash hit as
was the single from sarah with love
the last of seven albums in English real
love came out back in 2010 the Hamburg
born songstress then took a step back
from recording until she resolved to
make a comeback in her native language
but it wasn't as easy as she'd imagined
just letting go sales funnel you thought
that was the biggest challenge but
endless search for the right lyrics and
the right sound the acoustics and the
rhythm also had to be right the right
message at that moment that was the
toughest bit of warm feeling secure file
your nausea touch version the new album
tackles difficult themes in the
sliminess turn the 34 year old sings
about her own death very short vine and
bits of okla and bass down yeah you see
me Monica met ones in some of my
children heard the song once and never
want to hear it again they don't want to
think about their mum no longer being
there but still what surprise it was
important for me to say how I'd like
things to be when that happens
mismanagement Darwin for the pre release
preview the singer invited some of her
faithful following to her record
company's premises
refine the consensus they liked it a lot
despite it being in German one fan says
she used to think English was the only
language for music but this new sound
surprised her she liked it much more
than she expected I mother something up
the soap thank you shana society
balloonist I do think it's my most
personal record the most private and
most honest the first record in my own
words and her fans appreciate that the
genre vest has already become a top 10
hit this fall Sarah Connor will be
taking that first batch of German songs
on the road
you